so we have two intersecting lines here
and then we have this other purple
looking line and then they've given us
some angles they tell us that this the
measure of this angle right over here 7x
the measure of this angle right over
here is 60 degrees and the measure of
this angle right over here is X so let's
try to figure out what all of these
angles are so to do that we have to
figure out what X is and there's a big
clue here because 60 plus the 60 degree
angle plus the X angle their adjacent
and if you add these two angles together
their outer raise our vertical angle
with this 7x angle so we could say and
just to visualize that a little better
let me color it in so you see that this
let me do it this way you see you see
that this angle out here we do in a
color I haven't used yet this entire
angle right over here which is going to
be 60 degrees plus X that's a vertical
angle with this angle the one that has
measure 7x so we could say that 60
degrees plus X is equal to 7x because
vertical angles are equal so let's write
that down we get 60 and we'll assume
that everything is in degrees 60 Plus
let me do that in this other color 60
plus X is going to be equal to 7x and
now we just have to solve for X so the
simplest thing to do would be to get all
of our X's on one side of the equation
I've already gotten seven X's on this
right-hand side so let's bring let's get
let's get rid of all of the X's on the
left-hand side and the easiest way to
get rid of this X is to subtract X from
the left hand side but in of course in
order to keep it an equation we can't
just do something to one side otherwise
it won't be equal anymore we have to do
it to both sides so let's subtract X
from both sides and on the left hand
side we are left with just the 60 so
we're left with just a 60 and then that
is going to be equal to 7x minus X I
have 7 of something and I get rid of one
of them I'm going to have 6 of that
something left so that's going to be
equal to 6x so we have 6 times something
is equal to 60 you could probably figure
that out in your head but I will do a
little systematically we can divide both
by 6:00 to solve for X so let's do that
and we would be left with X is equal to
60 divided by 6 is 10 and we reminded
ourselves that everything was in degrees
and we could even do that here this was
in degrees this is in degrees and so
this is in degrees right over here so
the measure of this angle right over
here is 10 degrees so this one right
over there is 10 degrees this is of
course 60 degrees you add them together
60 degrees plus 10 degrees is 70 degrees
so this bigger angle right over here is
70 degrees and of course this one over
here it's a vertical angle it's going to
have to be the same and we see that 7
times X 7 times 10 degrees is 70 degrees
as well